Друзі, всім привіт! Традиція управління знизу виникла у Німеччині
ще у 12 столітті, коли почали з’являтися вільні від влади архієпископів міста
зі своїм військом, судами та правом самостійно збирати податки.
У цій серії пропоную розібратися, як організоване
сучасне німецьке самоуправління на рівні громади.
Німеччина поділена на 16 політико-адміністративних одиниць -
федеральні землі. Розгляньмо докладніше землю Північний Рейн-Вестфалія.
Вона складається з п’яти адміністративних округів.
Візьмімо адміністративний округ Кельн. Він, у свою чергу,
поділений на 8 районів та 4 міських округи.
Тепер спускаємося до рівня району - беремО район Райн-Зіґ.
Він розділений на 8 громад та 11 міст.
Розглянемо за приклад громаду Вахтберг.
Громада складається з 13 селищ. Її символ - дракон.
Дракон, тому що громада лежить на землях поблизу "Драхенфельс" -
скелі Дракона. Ця скульптура - подарунок від жителів Вахтберґа,
які самі його виготовили.
Юрґен Кляйкамп - член місцевої Ради громади Вахтберг.
Його партія Християнсько-демократичний союз (ХДС)
має тут найбільшу фракцію – 19 місць. Загалом у Раді – 49 депутатів
від шістьох партій і ще один позафракційний.
Профільні комітети Ради організовують життя громади.
Громада сама організовує побудову доріг місцевого значення,
планує і контролює будівельні роботи за узгодженням з районним керівництвом,
організовує роботу дитячих садків.
Також займається підтримкою бізнесу і намагається залучати
підприємців до громади.
А який же річний бюджет громади?
Дуже маленький! Близько 40 мільйонів євро.
Населення громади - 21 тисяча. Гроші до бюджету
надходять з податку на землю, плати за користування дорогами
та з оплати комунальних послуг. Очолює громаду - бургомістр,
який має не лише представницькі, а і реальні владні повноваження.
Зокрема, головує у найважливішому фінансовому комітеті.
Остаточні рішення у Раді і комітетах ухвалюються
колегіально, більшістю голосів.
Бургомістра обирають прямим голосуванням жителі громади терміном
на 5 років. У вересні 2020 року новим бургомістром
став Йорґ Шмідт з ХДС. Я домовився про зустріч
з його суперником на виборах - лідером  фракції Зелених громади Вахтберґ -
Олівером Генкелем. Поговоримо з ним про невдалі рішення громади.
На превеликий жаль, так сталося, що ось те дальнє дерево посаджене
на місці, де під час зібрань людей могла стояти сцена для вистав.
Тепер це взагалі не видається можливим.
Так вирішив комітет із будівництва.
Ось це дерево, яке привезли з розплідника і висадили посеред кам'яної площі.
Тепер члени Ради громади вирішуватимуть, куди його пересадити.
Мене вразило те, наскільки глибоко зачепила ця проблема пана Генкеля
і з яким обуренням він розповідав про невміння комітету
прорахувати на один крок уперед. А ось ще один обов'язок комітету з будівництва:
Громада відповідає за стан шкіл.
Це означає, що ми піклуємося лише про будівлі шкіл.
Ми не платимо зарплату вчителям, не впливаємо на процес навчання
та не забезпечуємо навчальними матеріалами -
це все справа земельного та окружного урядів.
Намотуючи десятки кілометрів мальовничими дорогами громади,
я замислився над тим, а хто ж відповідальний за їхній ідеальний стан?
Виявилося, що швидкісні траси - автобани - будуються і обслуговуються
з бюджету центрального уряду ФРН, дороги міжміського значення -
це сфера компетенції урядів земель, центральні дороги і площі
у містечках і селах - це гроші громади. А от побудова доріг у приватному
секторі лягає на плечі громадян.
Побудову цієї дороги між приватними будинками у селищі
мешканці оплатили зі своїх кишень.
У середньому вийшло 10 тисяч євро з одного будинку.
До побудови дороги належить і прокладання каналізації,
електромережі, газогону, водогону. Однак коли дорога вже збудована,
потім у разі потреби ремонту роботи вже оплачуватимуть
з бюджету громади, а не з кишень жителів.
Повз дорожні ремонти приїжджаю у містечко Адендорф.
Це - центр гончарства, який приваблює туристів з сусідніх регіонів.
Подивимось, як працюється малим підприємцям громади Вахтберґ.
Вітаю, мене звати Крістіан Ґюнтер. Я - гончар у п'ятому поколінні
і разом зі своєю дружиною є власником гончарної майстерні Ґюнтер.
Ласкаво просимо до нашого виробничого цеху!
Ось такий глиняний посуд для зберігання картоплі, цибулі та хліба -
візитівка регіону. За ним сюди приїжджають з усієї Німеччини.
Ціна ємності для зберігання хлібу, наприклад, 65 євро.
У нас немає найманих працівників.
Все виготовляємо самі, вручну. Ось воно тут стоїть.
Окрім мене працюють мої батьки, тато і мама, і моя дружина.
Це батько Крістіана. Він закладає в піч
нову партію кераміки для обпалення.
А сам Крістіан показує, як за 20 секунд він виготовляє
чашу для мюслей. Робота кипить, незважаючи на локдаун.
Під час епідемії коронавірусу замовлення від покупців гончарі
приймають по Інтернету. Завдяки онлайн-замовленням вдалося
уникнути критичного спаду продажів, тож майстерня
навіть не подавала заявку на допомогу від держави.
Крістіан каже, що найкорисніша допомога від місцевої влади
для нього - це заходи, які розширюють коло постійних покупців.
В Адендорфі проходить День гончарства. Місцева влада це підтримує, організовує.
Для проведення фестивалю раз на рік перекриває рух на вулицях містечка.
А протягом решти року туристів притягують до громади Вахтберґ
середньовічні фортеці на воді. Це справжня місцева родзинка.
Їх на території громади аж три.
Замок Адендорф, перша згадка про який датується 14-м століттям,
настільки великий, що зараз на його території проживають кілька родин.
Під час Другої світової сюди у двір впав літак.
Фортецю Ґуденау збудували у 13-му столітті.
Вона має розкішний барочний парк. Власниця обійстя - графиня
Генрієтте Штрасольда  - дозволяє усім охочим зайти на територію
з березня до грудня.
А це - найменша і найзатишніша, як на мене, водяна фортеця - Оденгаузен.
Її історія почалася в 11-му столітті з побудови центральної вежі.
2005-го року фортецю придбала родина Фітен,
яка мешкає тут разом з трьома дітьми.
Вхід до замку Оденгаузен охороняє лише ось ця базальтова брила.
Ну що ж, ходімо всередину!
І що ж ви думаєте робить мільйонер-власник замку?
Звичайно ж, порається по господарству!
Вольфґанґ Фітен запрошує всередину.
Він - власник фірми, яка організовує для німців поїздки на спортивні змагання
по всьому світу. На стінах - фото дружини, яка є його компаньйоном
по бізнесу та обличчям компанії.
У мене одразу ж виникає питання - чи зобов'язує закон власників
історичних пам'яток пускати охочих на територію?
Немає ніякого закону, який вимагає, щоб ми пускали туристів.
Це наше власне рішення.
Ми не пускаємо сторонніх у будівлю, бо ми тут живемо,
а погуляти у саду - це в порядку.
Звичайно ж, для громади Вахтберґ - це величезний плюс.
Бо власник пускає не лише туристів. Він також дозволяє
проводити у внутрішньому саду концерти та вистави.
Підтримання замку у такому стані - справа недешева.
2017 року ми провели масштабні реставраційні роботи.
Кошторис перевалив за півмільйона євро,
це вдвічі більше, ніж ми думали спочатку.
Згодом на певну частину цих коштів нам зменшили податки.
За словами власника, ще 20 років тому частину реставраційних робіт
могла профінансувати громада, однак зараз на це в бюджеті немає коштів.
Ба більше - на горизонті з'явилася загроза у вигляді забудовників.
За 200 метрів від фортеці може з'явитися
багатоповерховий житловий комплекс.
Це водяна фортеця. І вже 800 років підземне джерело
з Вахтберґа омиває її фундамент.
Так задумано будівельниками, однак якщо підвал та підземні гаражі
новобудови змінять течію і вода не надходитиме,
фортеця просто трісне і почне руйнуватися.
Окрім цього, якщо будівля буде вищою за фортецю, це порушить
архітектурний ансамбль, який не порушувався століттями.
Вольфґанґ Фітен протягом 8 років запрошував лідерів усіх політичних партій
з Ради громади на каву, пояснював їм ситуацію, показував фундамент.
За словами власника фортеці, всі ці роки його підтримували,
однак найближчими місяцями в Раді має відбутися
фінальне голосування з цього приводу.
За замком Оденгаузен, згідно плану зонування,
ухваленому Радою громади 2013 року, мають бути землі,
відведені під будівництво у місті Беркум.
Однак дискусії ще тривають і ми вирішуємо, що ж там
має з'явитися у найближчі місяці або роки, однак немає ще конкретних планів.
Залишається сподіватися, що місцева влада ухвалить виважене рішення.
Я стежитиму за подіями навколо замку Оденгаузен
і повідомлятиму вам в коментарях останні новини щодо цієї ситуації.
А ви тим часом пишіть,
що б ви хотіли ще дізнатися про Німеччину!
Нехай щастить!